[Music]
oh there's baby chicks yep two weeks old
I've gotta hold them
hi little friend I sent Bob some photos
and a description of Jill and Craig's
seven acre plot hoping he can offer
advice on the best way to actualize
their vision
okay this looks amazing so this is their
seven acre property there are these
Terraces that are already established I
put this other layer of the topography
or the Contours over this site
I kind of came up with this concept of
dividing the land
based upon the soil conditions and based
upon the topography and separated this
into two categories restoration through
reforestation and restoration through
cultivation
Craig can manage this yeah Joe can
manage this I love this his and hers
Farm yeah
the goal is you want to divide the land
up into smaller Parcels so that it's
more manageable yeah and it's also
easier to conceptualize I think for them
too right now it feels really
overwhelming yeah no for sure what can
they actually begin planting here you
need to be putting in the long-term
trees okay even though it's still early
in season Bob wants to show me his food
Forest before everything is in bloom so
I can have a better idea of what Craig
and Jill's Farm might look like in the
future some on three acres and before I
moved here this was nothing but a
Hayfield it's nothing but grass that
whole concept is to introduce as much
Native species as possible on the
perimeter of the property and then as we
move closer to the house have more
cultivated varieties and diversity of
fruits and vegetables and nuts and
things of that nature
so these are willows we have
Mulberry false Indigo hazelnut black
walnut sumac you know the soil is good
here so we start infilling herbs and
wildflowers oh no and this place in the
summer is just you can't see through it
because of the wildflowers and all the
vegetation
to try to fill in everything with some
sort of ground cover that's beneficial
to the land and beneficial to the
insects and everything and the food
Forest should be a mature forest with
the dense canopy
a food Forest canopy cover plays a
unique role in building a rich and
diverse edible food Forest
by incorporating seasonal ground
covering plants and shrubs under the
taller trees the soil conditions are
more likely to be optimal because of the
constant regeneration
[Music]
the way Bob filled out his food Forest
it's not just a hodgepodge of trees it's
very well planned out really beautiful
it's not just about design for him it's
about function and everything works
perfectly together in a system so you're
thinking from the top down is kind of
how you want to get from the top down
and I'm thinking 30 50 years out moving
backwards in time interesting you know
you're emulating nature here but you're
also kind of training it so that it's
not just taking over you don't need to
over complicate things at the beginning
stages nature is going to complicate
things for you so a more simplistic
approach that is easier to manage the
thing they keep in mind is think about
the food forest in 50 years and what's
that going to look like
it's helpful to see what Bob's Farm
looked like this time of year because it
kind of gives me a reference point I'm
excited to share Bob's plans with Craig
and Jill I hope that they like what he's
come up with
[Music]
foreign